okay welcome back let's get right into
audience questions first one david if
biden gets elected in november what do
progressives do next
so disclaimer disclaimer don't put the
cart before the horse everybody's got to
go vote there is no guarantee
that joe biden is going to get elected
uh republicans
are certainly planning some october
surprises we don't even know what they
are yet but certainly claiming victory
over coronavirus maybe
an emergency use vaccine maybe
more lies about economic numbers who
even knows but do not put the cart
before the horse every single one of us
needs to go out and vote
here is the analogy i've been using to
talk about a possible biden victory over
trump
biden winning doesn't score us any
points biden winning gives us the ball
back we've been playing defense the
entire time
trump has been president so if we get
the ball back
that's when we have to then put together
our strategy for how to put some points
on the board now this reminds me
of the importance of getting control of
the senate and maintaining control
in the house because joe biden is not
the most progressive
candidate but he's not likely to veto
legislation
that makes it through the house and
senate
now the devil is in the details there
you might imagine something like
medicare for all and you might say
biden would veto medicare for all he
says he's not for it well
medicare for all is not going to pass
the senate right that's what you and
this is not
don't attack the messenger even many
democratic senators don't support
medicare for all
and if the democrats get a majority in
the senate it would be a small one maybe
with 53 or 54
senators medicare for all is not going
to make it to joe biden's desk so let's
not let's think of you know more
realistic examples and
virginia is a very realistic example
you've got a moderate democratic
governor
with the democratic legislature and
they've gotten progressive things done
and we've seen virginia move to the left
significantly even with a moderate
democratic governor but like i've said
before
a biden win is the start so extend
house control hopefully take control of
the senate and then
in the immediate joe biden needs to be
pressured
to reverse the insane trump executive
orders that have accumulated while
donald
trump has been in the oval office and
then the house and senate need to go to
work biden is going to have to be pushed
and he's going to have to be pushed hard
and
what what i've been trying to
communicate for some time now is
even if biden isn't as progressive as
bernie
and he's nowhere near as progressive as
bernie sanders
biden is running on what if he were
elected president would be the most
progressive platform that a sitting
president has had
just think through this right biden
is accused by many of being barely a
centrist there's people say this guy's
almost like a moderate republican
if you look at biden's tax plan the way
i did on monday this week
it's well to the left of barack obama's
if you look at the things that are in
biden's tax plan abolishing
the lower rate for capital gains uh
dramatically expanding the social
security
um uh tax on people earning above four
hundred thousand dollars a year
eliminating the stepped-up basis i mean
there's not even a uh what what joe
biden wants to do tax-wise is well to
the left of barack obama if you look at
biden's health care plan
it's obviously not medicare for all but
it is obamacare
plus a bunch of stuff to the left of
obama including
biden has said he would be supportive of
lowering the age for medicare and a
bunch of other things it is not medicare
for all but the point is
if biden gets it done what he wants to
do
would be the left most position public
option etc it's ob what obama
started from which is public option with
more stuff like lowering the medicare
age biden supports the green new deal as
a framework
and uh that is something that i mean
green new deal wasn't even a term
uh back then so my point is not that
biden is
the uber progressive hero my point is
biden has already made it clear that if
he were president
his policy would be the most progressive
of anyone
who has been president not who has run
okay
and he's got to be held to it and he has
to be given
the ability through the house and senate
to actually get things done and that's
why
if biden gets elected we've gotten the
ball back that's when the offense starts